you were on call her daddy yeah and you
talked to her about getting sober and
it's around 2 years uh two years January
2nd okay oh congratulations thank you
thank congratulations oh there it is
thank you so much I stopped drinking
alcohol was my poison I'm not sober I
don't work a program but it's alcohol
for me and I didn't say anything funny
enough it was Gail King who got it out
of me saw her this love ABS mornings
were you were you ready to talk about it
or did it just kind of I was at the
2-year Mark okay something happens at
the two two year at least for me what is
it is it time under our belts is it a
little more confidence in it yeah I feel
like the first year I was just like okay
stay safe stay home you know certain
elements of my life fell away new people
came into my life but I felt like my
second year I learned like I was having
fun I learned how to I um gave a new
definition to fun like it just looks
different these days I was like going
out I was going to the dinners I was
going to the events I wasn't avoiding
anything I'm having a revelation right
now which is listening to your story I'm
wondering if is that that when you have
a behavior that you know is not serving
you MH I think we lose trust in
ourselves that we're never going to
break that cycle yeah and somewhere
around 2 years was when I started to
trust myself maybe and I'm I'm not I
didn't know it then you saying what
you're saying yeah is making me think
maybe that's a good time to put it out
into the world to your peers to other
people to plant that flag in the sand
when you've earned time and trust and
you can trust your choices like I think
the for me it was like oh I just feel
safe in my body again I wouldn't give
this feeling up for anything the fact
that you talk so openly about this like
there's no telling how many people
you've helped you've inspired me you
inspired me it's just amazing and then
it's just a ripple effect and I think if
more people in general but especially
women can show like The Dirty gross ugly
parts that we don't want to talk about
like I think that is beautiful and brave
and So Co I agree I
agree that's what beauty is I think that
your new film that I'm so obsessed with
it's it gives me the 51st dates sort of
marching orders of like let's talk about
how our relationship really works really
is don't give me the romcom fantasy
always give me a dose of how do we make
relationship work talk about looking at
our patterns things we've done basically
what usually happens in a romcom at the
end happens at the beginning so like
these my character and Nat's character
they hook up at the beginning and you're
like well okay well the movie's done but
what really happens is they're both like
okay I gotta I gotta show I gotta show
Who I Really Am be transparent and so we
we go through all their uh love stories
and flashbacks of of what's made them
who they are today exactly is Nat coming
we're bringing Nat oh he's here 100%
when we come back we're going to be
joined by Lucy's co-star Nat wolf for a
balloon pop quiz don't go anywhere